pray for those innocent human beings
innocent Souls while we're crying for
them they God willing will be rejoicing
in Jenna we have to be positive even at
times like this because they're being
positive at times like this and what
about us what do we have to cry for
compared to what they're going through
it's a great reflection for us to to
really count the blessings that we have
to really be thankful if they're able to
thank God Almighty Allah in those dire
situations what about us what excuse do
we have Allah is the most wise Allah is
the most just they're inshallah seeing
the other side and they're rejoicing in
joy and we make Dua that we can Unite
with our brothers and sisters our loved
ones in Jenna